this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
monday
i think it's the 20th who gives a [__]
the joint is brought to you by manscape
listen just when you thought they were
done
manscape is back with the most
comfortable boxes anywhere they're
tremendous these are boxes 2.0 tagless
and made of buttery soft micro fabric
you'll want to pair these for every
occasion
this is all new underwear features a
jewel pouch to keep your freshly shaved
balls in their own little comfort place
plus you didn't hear this from me you
could store [__] in there you know what
i'm saying choose from an arrangement of
designs and colors sizes from small to
3x to big dick mcgick you know what i'm
saying
get 20 percent off plus free shipping
with code joey at
manscape.com again that's 20 off plus
free shipping with code joey at manscape
listen i can't tell you the good things
about manscape i shaved an eyebrow with
these [__] the other day you
could shave your balls your [__] it's
[__] almost july and you still got
that [__] monster of
a dust ball between your [__] legs
and then you complain i don't get no
[__] nothing it's time for you to get
manscaped sucker take care of yourself
from the underwears to the premium
package to the [__] lip gloss
manscaped is here to take care of you if
you're a man get on manscape get 20 off
plus free shipping with code joey at
manscape.com your balls will thank you
the joint is also brought to you by
freeze pipe listen no matter how it gets
outside i don't give a [__] if they send
you to hell you keep your bong ice cold
with the freeze pipe just freeze it pack
it and rip that [__] when you
rip the hot smoke passage through the
frozen part cooling down the smoke
as you inhale it living like a [__]
doctor your smoke would be so cold you
think you're in the [__] north pole
getting a finger in the ass from a
penguin you understand me i love the
freeze pipe [__] love it
do you understand me i got the little
one they even sent me like a an
extension now it's like a [__] pipe
whether you go with the bung the pipe or
the bubbler you can't lose the freeze
pipe is non-toxic
it freezes better and faster than water
and stays frozen longer it's like a [__]
on a limited viagra freeze pipe cools
down to smoke by hundreds of degrees
listen
you uncle joey's here to take care it's
gonna be a hot summer why [__] up your
throat live like a doctor with the
freezepipe.com
and pressing code joey to save ten
percent
off your first order that's 10 percent
whether you get the bung the pipe or the
[__] bubbler if you want to see the
devil it starts with freeze pipe
thefreezepipe.com
pressing code joey to save 10
if you could smoke it from freeze pipe
freeze pipe makes it
go to freeze pipe dot com code joey and
now without further ado it's monday
morning let's get this [__]
party started yeah
[Music]
hey how you doing
come on
welcome to uncle joy's joy
[Music]
do
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday
the 20th of june
it's a beautiful [__] day to be alive
was a great [__] weekend thank you
very much for all the father's day
wishes whatever the [__] you call them
i'll tell you what i had a great day on
father's day i had one of the best
father's days
i ever had in my life so thank you
i didn't do much i just hung out with my
wife and my daughter
went swimming at my brother's [__] like
that but
i had nothing on my mind
i started this on friday this week i
started going into [__] father's day
mode
we had a little barbecue friday night we
had to go to another party saturday
afternoon
and then saturday night we went to see
bill burr he was [__] tremendous as
usual i want to thank him and dean del
rey for inviting me to the show
and uh that's it man it was a great
[__] weekend it's a great week coming
up i don't know if you guys been
following bert on instagram
but those shows
look [__] great
you know man uh
i [__] hate working for comedians
when you become a comic there's always
guys that you came up with and then one
day they're like hey i'm booking a room
or
hey i own a comedy club between you and
i nine or ten of those guys
buy a comedy club because they're not
funny so they figure if they have a
comedy club they could buy their own
stage time i'm not talking online here
i'm saying the truth here
and uh
you know you're [__] uh what are we
talking about you know what the [__] i'm
talking about here i'm high already
bert's tour and when you do something
like there was there was a club only
years ago that contacted me
for a show and i i lived two hours away
from the show at the time that had to be
10 12 years ago
and the guy
was paying me for a show on like a
thursday night
and
he wanted me to do
5 45 radio
two hours away from my house
and then
stay up there the rest of the day radio
is like 30 minutes
so i'm going to be in some [__] str i
forget that i forget what town it was it
wasn't a strange town but i'm gonna be
in this town
from 6 15 on i got to wait till 8
o'clock at night so i asked the guy do
you have a hotel
that i could check in and the guy goes
there's no hotels we don't give out
hotels i go then dog i can't do the
[__] radio because i'm not going to
go all the way [__] up there
and then just sit there with my thumb up
my ass all day you only pay him i think
he was only paying me like a deuce
and [__] uh you know [__] you i'm not
doing it he got pissed this guy like hey
man you give me the [__] hotel room
i'll do radio now i'm not staying up
there oh [__] day
and we parted and we were friends and
that's it and i made a point there was a
lot of there's a lot of other rooms that
the people started out as comics and
whatever sometimes they're pretty
good people
but sometimes they get weird and uh they
see you making a check and they're
[__] stuck in a club and it's kind of
weird
but my point is that sometimes comics
they don't they forget
they forget of what it's like when you
go into a comedy club and there's no
green room
guys i'm not j i'm not always presently
i don't need a [__] green room
but without a green room or somewhere to
put us
you got people just mingling that
they're on top of you before the show
and you know what i came from the school
that you don't want to see people before
the show
when you come out on stage you want to
be that person so if they see you
off the [__] beaten path they're
gonna go you're just another joke that's
not the way i look at things if you came
to atlantic city shows i was out there
talking to people before rogan came on i
don't give a [__] about that [__] but
little things you know bert on this tour
has been a complete [__] gentleman to
me
uh
i mean the flights are easy
but the food how they contacted me and
they're like what's your favorite snack
what's your favorite alcoholic beverage
what's your favorite they sent me a
[__] sheet
like what's your favorite non-alcoholic
beverage what's your favorite alcoholic
beverage what's your favorite food what
are your favorite snacks what fruit do
you like i mean come on guys who [__]
caters to you like this he
[__] called m m's he sent me pictures
because they're like listen we're going
to be on the bus if you want a hotel
when we get there but take a look at the
bedrooms on the bus
holy [__]
there's five buses
and i think it's you're in there with
two other guys the the [__] bat the
bedroom is gorgeous
they got everything in there that you
[__] need plus he's got a bus just
filled with food
plus he's got another bus that you go
into and there's a game room and stereos
and [__] computers and [__] this is
he went off
and i saw you see any of the videos mike
[__] just beautiful what those fields
look like so i'm really proud of bert
i'm really proud to be a part of this
i was on the fence i'm not gonna lie to
anybody i've been on the fence i'm out
of this [__] thing a year
you know
but i'll tell you what i'm just gonna
it's a four-day mini camp
like when you want to get good at
something you got to go on triple runs
why because it's six weeks like you just
go give me six weeks you look at your
mom and say i'm gonna see you for six
weeks i'm gonna go camping just look at
it as a camping trip that's why you do
triple runs in the summer they'll [__]
with you and say we got to pay you less
money but who gives a [__] you're living
in a tent
you know you'll take the hotel room
you'll take the oregon run you'll take
all those runs
and you'll live in a hotel room three
four nights a week maybe you could
squeeze a hotel out of a guy an extra
night but for two nights you're just out
there in wilderness you're in idaho
you're in oregon you're in montana just
go [__] camping you know these and
this is what bert's done
like we're gonna be on a [__] bus
hotels i'm only taking two planes which
that's you know i don't know how many
[__] flights got canceled last week
every day last week i saw dean delray
had a seven hour delay
bill burr had a long delay ari and mark
norman got [__] delayed so i'm
praying listen i get delayed i'm not
going nowhere
you understand me they come at me with a
seven hour wait time i'm not gonna go
nowhere let me tell you something when i
fly home from [__] texas that's what
i'm really scared of after a seven hour
bus ride
going into an airport smelling like 10
dead iranians and [__] your balls are
sweaty i don't know what you have no
they have a whole bus that's just got
showers
no no he did bert went all out burke
went all out and i told people on my
patreon podcast last week i'm like
listen guys
there's people that you might not like
you know like they rub you the right
wrong way hey that's what life is all
about but
before you make an assumption or
whatever about them let me tell you
something anybody who's good to me and i
tell you they're good to
i appreciate if you're nice to them even
if you don't like them because they do a
lot for me i mean bert's taking care of
everybody on this talk nikki
dave vettel i mean dave bert is
treating us like comics should be
treated and uh
i got nothing wrong with that i got the
utmost respect for people like that you
know that they don't forget
of where the [__] they come from or
they're going to swallow all the profit
for themselves
i don't think bird will break evil in
this
i mean we gotta let's say we sell out
all the shows next week i don't even
think bird will break even guys you got
eight hitters on this show
that he's taking off the road so you got
to pay them their [__] money
on top of that he's the buses are
[__] beautiful everything is
state-of-the-art dog they sent me a link
for a website
that you log into every day when you're
on tour with them it tells you
everything for the day
like
yeah like like breakfast is like
eight to 11 is gonna be served like you
go on that bus whenever you want get
breakfast
then lunch from 12 to four
then mid evening snack from six to eight
you know they got everything there for
you to eat while you wait the only thing
i don't like is the long walk
from the [__] trailer to the stage
i'm gonna i'm not my [__] tap out but
i'll just get like a scooter or
something and go up there early and
[__] get out
i'm
sure scooter on the back
you know you
when you're a comic
you see a lot of
shitty things when you start now you
know you get thrown into shitty things
so
it's always good to see somebody taking
care of comics the right way some i love
bert crysia and i am fired up to see you
[__] we're going to south
carolina
[__] bristol tennessee maybe that
chick
that sucked my dick in knoxville show up
that was she's 40 now so
she's a little older than her husband's
like 50. i still need my 40 hours
we're hitting [__] atlanta uh some
part of georgia
and we're hitting uh mississippi i got
some dear friends in mississippi
from boulder i can't wait to [__] see
him so
guys i'm excited so thank you for always
having my back and thank you for the
encouragement i went out thursday night
i did [__] uncle vinnie's and i got
to tell you something guys
i got back with the pandemic hit and uh
we all got off stage in march
some people got on stage right away i
took about six months off i didn't get
back on stage in september
i felt that i was flat
and then i waited about a couple weeks i
did another show and i was still very
flat and
i didn't know what was going on with me
so i just took like another month off
and then i finally said what the [__] is
wrong with me
let me book some shows at uncle
vinnie's and go down and work this out
guys i did like three months
couldn't get nowhere couldn't get to the
material couldn't get to the character
felt clunky up there it just didn't feel
right and i didn't want to do it anymore
i took a little [__] breather
and then it was time it was just time
for me i was trying to lose my mind here
at the house and it was time for me just
to just go out and see how it feels you
know
and i went out and it still felt a
little clunky but i felt a little better
like i don't know i don't know how to
describe it i kept going up you came to
the benefit with jimmy and and then you
came to the rich boss thing and
there was still something not going on
with me
and it was until i hit
the stress factory with brian cowan that
i figured out
everybody's got jokes
and here i was worried about the jokes
what was going on was
the character the character coco needed
to come back and be [__] silly and
and whatever so it took time and
guys all those sets i must have done 20
sets that i can't got in that car
and i felt like [__]
you know like when uh you say the wrong
thing
and somebody corrects you and you're
like oh sorry about that like you know
how's your husband my husband died
yeah you know something like that you
know
and you get in your car you're like damn
i stuck my foot in my mouth that's how i
felt after those 20 25 sets
thursday night was the best that i've
had
since the pandemic since march 2nd of
2019 whatever the [__] the pandemic was
that was the best that i had
since i walked off the main room and ali
wang hugged me and i [__] almost had
a heart attack like that was
thursday night i drove home and i got to
be honest here i had to pull over and
take two hits of the vapor pen like what
the [__] just happened
you know like i said on the podcast last
week the patreon but you
you know without [__] the character
you're not spitting out this [__]
you know once i realized what i was
gonna do
who i was again and what direction i
wanted to take it
piece of [__] cake piece of [__]
cake
i was so proud of myself i was like wow
this is uh pretty [__] impressive so
i'm happy that you guys supported me i'm
happy that you had my back i'm happy
that when i came and did such you were
like joey you killed no i didn't but i
appreciate the love i love you
[__] just the same you guys
know this [__]
you know what we're talking about
artists and stand-up
i talk to a lot of young comics maybe on
uh well i'm on facebook jail but i'm
still allowed to [__] uh
i'm still allowed to
you know send messages i got a couple
comics that always
send me messages i got a couple guys on
patreon that hit me up for advice from
time to time they let me know what
they're doing i'm just like a sounding
board for them
you know listen i can't look at
somebody's set and tell you whether
you're good or bad i mean who the [__]
am i
there's not not much i could do to
help you i could just guide you
you know and i could give you advice on
what to do and some of the advice you
agree with and some of the advice you're
going joey this is something that
you forgot you do at your level no
i did some crazy [__]
at an early [__] level that
got me to where i am because
a lot of people will try to knock you
off your [__] track when you're doing
comedy in the beginning
a lot of people try to discourage even
your friends your family
your close ones i mean it's it's it's a
[__] up thing
and it hurts your feelings but sometimes
you go you know what it's just they're
trying to protect me and i get it you
know people say [__] to you like you're
an [__] you're doing this gig for
free you know mike and i were talking
about amp
i did an amp show the other night i i
appreciate you guys that tuned in
i would appreciate more you guys just
downloading the amp
app and i'm going to tell you why number
one i don't make a dime off amp guys and
near do you guys number two it doesn't
cost you anything guys not a [__]
thing
but i told mike while i was doing that
amp last week i was very happy that i
did it like i [__] felt a euphoria
over me
it was like doing cocaine for the first
time honest to god you're gonna go joy
from doing a stupid radio show from
playing
guys the possibilities are [__]
endless with amp
when i woke up
wednesday morning and mike said he had
done an amp show i was so [__] happy
i was so [__] happy because for the
last 10 years all you [__] been
asking me how do you start a podcast how
do you do this
finally the ship is here no more [__]
excuses [__]
amp you don't need
a [__] microphone
you don't need a camera
mike what do you need nothing just an
iphone at this point just an iphone okay
all right you need to spend 600 on an
iphone you already got our [__]
iphone it don't matter you make your
videos
you go on your apps you watch your
[__] porn whatever the [__] now i'm
giving you something i'm giving you an
opportunity and you're like jerry what
do you think listen
when you want to start a podcast you got
to buy two microphones a
[__] board whatever the [__]
the little thing that they have on uh
and they sell on instagram you know be
your own podcast producer with the
switches and [__] all that [__] cost you
money and i get it you know you have to
come up with the investment and joey how
am i going to make that money back well
you're asking all the [__] wrong
questions like everybody else does in
this country they ask the wrong question
not the question you should be asking
how much is going to cost or how am i
going to make my money back first off
you're doing something you love doing
i mean i could go the [__] i could have
a special olympic
[__] amp tournament okay and have
like a bunch of kids number one i
figured out amp i am
the dumbest computer person in the
[__] world okay
and i just sat there and figured out amp
and i picked the songs and the songs
disappeared one day and you know it's a
struggle you know what i'm saying but
when i was on amp
like 20 minutes in like the first speech
i gave out who the [__] knows
but like 20 minutes in
all i kept thinking about was joe rogan
i kept thinking about joe rogan joe
rogan i'll tell
people [__] cry constantly in life
and trust me i've been on that
and also when you're an artist when
you're [__] struggling
to make ends meet or to get to the
destination that your goal is
you [__] get down on yourself from
time to time you know you don't know and
you get frustrated and you look at
somebody who's doing better
you might get a little jealous of them
you know we've all been in that same
position but
you're not getting the [__] point of
this
when joe rogan got into the ufc
he called dana wright and he said listen
i'd like to come and announce the shows
i don't want any money i don't know if
it was
a year after he did those for free
then he finally got a paid gig on the
ufc
it was something that joe loved
joe has always loved fighting when i met
joe he gave me a [__] speech one
night
about the klitschko brothers in russia
right i mean joe was going deep with
this on me in the back and it was one of
the most inspirational speeches you ever
told me about russian how the klinko
brothers whatever the [__] they are
[Music]
liquid iv [__] suckers
anyway
he's telling me all this [__]
and i'm amazed guys i was blown the [__]
away from the 30-minute
story he told me on the klitschko
brothers obviously he loved fighting at
the same time
you know he's going to vegas to do these
events i don't know i'm going to use
okay see you later see you monday
and for a year he did him out of his own
pocket
he bought his own plane ticket he bought
his own meals he bought his own hotel
room
and he would go to [__] vegas and do
these and after a year one day they
offered him a [__] job
and what was it what is it 15 [__]
years later he's
he's sure rogan on the ufc and i know
they [__] pay him a lot of [__]
money it don't take a brain surgeon
right so
this is a guy that everybody always
always waiting for my ship to come in
what is my ship going to come in when is
my ship going to come in war
[__]
here's your [__]
but joey i don't know much about music
who gives a [__]
they got empty you could do anything on
that you don't even have to put music
you could just do a talk show and just
put the three topics sports
sex
and [__] uh you know
entertainment whatever you don't guys
it's over the excuses is over
there's no book to teach you how to do a
podcast it's it's you're learning as
you're going along but this is
everything is set up for you there i
mean i i was going i thought that you
had to set the songs up
before you do the show
dog no
you could do white that's how i picked
robert uh richard pryor i thought it was
gonna [__] blow up like i thought i
was like i'm gonna press this and the
[__] system's gonna go and they're
all gonna call me an [__] i pressed
that [__] i pressed richard
pryor
wino versus dracula boom it [__]
worked guys this is
you know i told mike i go mike i'm
scared i picked four songs
if we do this every week and we each
pick four songs at the end of the year
what's that bill gonna come to let me
know remember those napster bills and
they came and [__] people were [__]
going nuts you always eight hundred
thousand dollars for downloaded music so
i didn't want to take a chance like that
so
guys it's a [__] opportunity to have
i don't know what you're waiting on
sports what are the topics that they
have that bunch of [__]
because you got to pick your music your
genre of music like if you just want to
play
rock metal disco
funk pop
you know they have so i mean i think
it's the best [__] app because we've
had apps before where you could
you know like watch a game and put the
game through the tv
and you could be the announcer and then
yeah we had that for a long time but
then when you got a lot of followers
if the system blew they couldn't handle
200 people
i had i think 300 290 around there 290
around there and then it drops and it
picks back up again then it drops and it
picks back up again i didn't care about
the numbers i don't care about any of
that [__]
it's doing it it's like when people say
to me joy i i want to go on stage well
go on stage well i need to write
material no you know trust me the first
time you ain't gonna remember that
material you can do all the writing you
want all the memory dynamics you want
you can eat all the delta what's that
[__] that you eat fish salmon that's got
in it that's [__] you can eat all the
salmon you want trust me when you get on
that stage the first time you see 80
sets of eyeballs that's 160 eyes
staring at you you're not going to
remember [__] anyway i've been doing it
30 years and there's times i go out and
i see all these eyes and you forget what
the [__] you're gonna say just do it
same thing with this amp thing
download it wait to get the [__]
thing in the mail the email
download your songs give it a [__]
name for me it's the uncle joey power
hour you know that's it because i used
to listen to the flower power hour that
was an old show in the [__] 70s in
new york city but guys this is the
opportunity you've been waiting for i
[__] love it i just got to figure out
like i'll do another show this week i'll
try to do wednesday night
i gotta find the night where i'm
consistent with it i want to be very
consistent with it if you do an eight
o'clock show that's five o'clock in l.a
people in their cars i don't know if you
could download the app to your car i
think you can um
so i just got to find a more
settled
whatever the [__] you know dynamic
yeah i just got to find the better
[__] time to do it
i was talking about young comics before
enough with the amp app you're going to
download it and you're going to [__]
love it and i'm going to keep doing
these shows and
guys i found a lot about [__]
obstacle skill music on there there's a
lot of obstacles school and music you
know when i first signed up and i'm like
led zeppelin gonna be on here what
everything's [__] on there so give
the amp a look
download it and we'll listen to each
other that's it how's that it's like we
each have a [__] can with a string on
it now that's how [__] cool this is
right we could all communicate with each
other so what the [__]
i wanted to talk to you about the story
that i was thinking about because a
comic hit me up the other day
said he went out to a club in ohio and
the [__]
club person was an [__] to him the
whole weekend
they were featuring and after that
weekend they thought about quitting and
you know and i talked to the guy i was
like listen don't ever quit over some
jerk or [__]
comedy club owner or some [__] jerk
off comedy club booker you know
i was doing comedy about six years
my eyes were wide open my nose is wide
open you know
i just wanted to do good guys i just
didn't want to be a criminal no more
and i started you know uh
going outside my comfort zone i started
doing bellingham i was living in seattle
i was doing all these little clubs i
tried to get into harvey's in portland
and there was this club
in idaho called the funny boat
it was supposedly a [__] great club
we're going to talk about two booking
people
here at this story and
because both of these [__] booking
people tried to knock the cells
the wind out of my sails but
even as a young comic
i uh
you know
we take a lot of [__] when we're
struggling because
we don't know any better you know you
don't know any better you're scared
you don't want to develop a reputation
and then nobody will hire you so
you take a lot more [__] than you
usually would
you learn to ignore it for a while
you know i never really
listened i was getting [__] on from day
one except that the comedy works
everybody was cool to me
but any other gig you had there's always
some part of that gig that you're gonna
get [__] on and it's just a part of
you know it it's that's why i advise you
don't watch the molly crew movie it's
it's not like that for everybody you're
not just gonna go up on stage and
they're clapping and throwing underwear
yeah that's a [__] pipe dream it's a
good pipe dream to have because it's
going to happen
but you got to put in the [__] hard
work you know so
i get this call i'm i'm you know just
expanding my horizons and this is funny
bone club and i forget what the girl's
name was that managed that you know
she was a woman of the world you know
she wore a hat with the feather and the
whole
she was too cool for school routine you
know and uh
when i called her i kind of felt that
you know i
joey diaz a friend of mine gave me a
reference to work your club she's like
well i looked at your tape and
i hope you decide to clean it up before
you come up here and all this [__] i'm
like yeah whatever
because you tell them whatever to get
into the club then when you're there who
gives a [__] whatever they tell you
listen we want you to wear a bunny hat
sure
right good yeah [__] you once you get
there oh you forgot i forgot the bunny
hat huh
i had it also i can't believe it my
daughter was crying on the way out
[__] bunny hat so
i get to the idaho funny bone and this
[__] i get you know you drive
whatever six seven hours nobody's you're
not getting enough money for a [__]
plane so i drive my six seven hours from
seattle
and you know you get to the club they
tell you you know you calling me i'm
leaving today when do you think you'll
be here well i'm leaving at nine i
should be there by [__] poor
so she goes all right i'll have somebody
in the office whatever so
you do your [__] driving you you
don't eat you're broke
you're looking at the e because you
barely get the money to get there and
you get there you're flustered you're a
little tied you stretch
and i get to the comedy club to get the
keys to the condo and the comedy club is
closed even though i had talked to the
night before and that morning there's
nobody at the [__] club now i gotta
go to a pay phone
and call them and she goes oh i'm sorry
i'm getting my head done
i'll be down there in
45 minutes and i got to sit in my
[__] car i got to get a [__]
subway veggie and cheese sandwich
eat half of it
because i can't
[__] get any i can't eat anything
else until i get a draw i barely had the
two thousand quarters to get the [__]
veggie and cheese sandwich so now you're
frustrated you know your family's eating
[__] cheeseburgers and [__] you just
talk to your friends in boulder they're
making steaks on the grill you're in
[__] idaho eating [__]
a subway sandwich okay
she pulls in
i go up i see her going and she goes can
you give me five minutes please
i go okay
i ain't this a [__] so
finally i opened the door goes it okay
now
she goes yeah come in come to the back
come to my office so when i go into
office
i go that was a hell of a ride and i
pull her chair and i sit down and she
goes did i tell you to sit
and i go it's going to be one of these
[__] weekends
right away
note this [__] lady says to me oh by
the way you're staying at a hotel
i go there why am i here
to pick up a key to the condo she goes
they're fixing the condo we're just
going to put you in a hotel like really
in a [__] way after she tells me
that she ask me to sit down
i'm a 500 a week comic [__] eight
shows nine shows
like all right you know i just wasted a
[__] hour and a half of my life that
i'm not gonna get back i could have just
gone straight to the hotel but the whole
way the whole day she's telling me that
she's [__] uh
obviously put me in a condo so
the headline is chris titus
all right chris was very cool then you
know i met him outside with a [__]
skateboard he's on the skateboard and
[__] i'm like what the [__]
he's skating all around town
chris is a great guy
i'm opening for him you know little did
i know it chris got a show
years later the titus what was his name
titus
he was writing that show while we were
there that week
like this is 1996 because when i got to
la in 98
i went to the improv one night and titus
was doing a one-man show
and i forgot i'd go oh that's who you
were writing it was yeah i finally got
it fox is gonna buy it so titus is great
everything was great
i think the week started on tuesday
tuesday wednesday thursday through
[__] sunday
so
all right everybody's hunky dory
we do the shows and me and chris are
getting along we have no problem and i
think like after three shows thursday
she calls me in the office she calls me
in the hotel one day she's like hey
can you come over to the office i need
to talk to you
i didn't know what you want to talk to
me about
i get there now this lady had control
she was really good friend like she was
a hippie chick that just thought she
wasn't even good looking
she thought that she was good friends
with somebody who booked all the funny
bone and the word on the street was
if she liked you
you could work the rest of the [__]
funny bones
so when i went up there
yeah guys what the [__]
i'm looking for work i'm looking to go
up there and make a great impression but
i could tell from the minute i walked in
there this lady was not buying my
[__] act at all now she wants to see
me i got called for like in the mafia so
i'm i don't know what to expect i go
over there i'm like what's up she goes
we got like three complaints
about your material
and i'm like
okay
what kind of complaints and she's like
well
you said a joke about this and i'm like
at that time i was a little rougher guys
you know this is 95.
96 i was a little rougher i i didn't
understand what offensive meant
i knew that i worked dirty and i knew
that people had told me if you work
dirty as a feature act you're not going
to get work i did not believe that i let
that fall off my [__] shoulders
you know i believed in the power of the
headliner and i believed in what i could
do and what i couldn't do
and you know i wasn't working that dirty
at the time she's sitting across from me
telling me that i'm offensive whatever
and that if i don't clean up my act
she's gonna have to let me go home and
get another comic for the weekend i'm
[__] crushed guys
i'm crushed okay you know i'm just
trying to make a good impression i'm
just trying to become a [__] comic
i leave that man and
i go to my room and i'm like this is not
gonna work for me at all
you know and as i started to open my
notebook and
just work clean i just thought about
bill hicks
and i thought about andrew dice clay and
guys i wasn't even in the [__]
neighborhood then
i was not even in that neighborhood i
didn't even
i couldn't even see myself even being
successful as a comic but before i
became a comic i became a man and i
[__] made a decision
to stick to that material and i didn't
make a [__] change of it
i didn't give a [__]
i went back to that friday
and i guess what now i added anger to
that [__] tone so i was slicing that
[__] room apart as a feature act
i was slicing that [__] room apart as
a feature act even titus is looking at
me a little weird she called me in again
and she's like tame it down i did not
[__] tame it down in fact i went to
the bar and i went to buy a package i
got and then i went to get a draw from
him she gave me a rough time about a
draw like we don't give draws here i'm
like listen i need the 50 [__] bucks
i need the [__] money what do you
mean don't give drugs draws i've already
worked six [__] shows that's whatever
the [__] it is i got like 800 400 in
credit
give me 50 bucks so we got to an
argument about the [__] 50 bucks so
i went back to the club and i i asked
some chick for [__] coke and she goes
i can't get you cocaine there's no
cocaine in this town just meth
i go [__] it give me a 10 bag of meth
who gives a [__] i was so upset i go
back to the hotel room on a friday night
i did a [__] line of that met i was
out of my mind and i [__] sit down
to watch tv and on showtime there's a
show called the dirty dozen
a comedian show
and i turn it on and it's like three
shows i sat there
on the meth and i watched don barrera
did a set that i [__] was blown away
by
somebody else did a set
and then joe rogan to the set
i didn't even know who joe rogan was he
had a backwoods hat on
he had hair he was live from boston or
whatever the [__] they did it i had no
idea who the [__] guy was i turned it
off it's not like i didn't have a
computer i couldn't look him up or don
marrero i just knew who dahmer was from
before that but right there made up my
decision that's what i want to do
and i had read all those richard pryor
books and lenny bruce books at the time
and i [__] went to the rest i think i
had uh
three shows on saturday and one on
sunday
i [__] rapped i
ripped through that [__] room those
four shows
and when i went to get paid that night
she goes you know what i saw that you
never even paid attention to me or
whatever
don't ever call me for a recommendation
you're never working for me again and i
looked and i go i don't give a [__]
and you know what
three years later she quit the [__]
business
she threatened me like you're never
gonna work any more funny bones
like i don't give a [__] you know good
luck
and for when you walk out of there
you're a little scared you just
went up against the [__] grain of
what you want to do
and for me i had nothing else i could do
i didn't have a mom and a dad who had a
paint shop you know what i'm saying
i can't get a civil job i can't i didn't
give a [__] that's what a comedian does
we stand on what we believe in and
whether you're you know the other day uh
i was with my daughter in the car
listening to tom morello
we're driving back and tom morello was
doing a june 19 song
so
he you know he played [__] the police
you know by uh
nwa
and uh
my daughter's like wow that's
kind of kind of weird you know she's
[__] nine
she's getting raised to do the right
stuff so we when we pulled over i talked
to her i said you know it's a rap song
and they had a lot of [__] problems
with the cops
but i go next time it's on i want you to
watch a scene with me when
the cops the detroit cops actually sat
nwa down
and said you're not allowed to do this
song i'm not allowed to do that song and
if we hear [__] the police we are
obviously going to arrest you
for vague or you know whatever
obstruction and all this [__]
and uh
the guy that played that manager was
like listen you guys got to do what you
got to do don't play the song
they're up on stage ripping that room
apart and [__] the guy that's
supposed to play ice cube
looks over at the dude they give each
other a look listen
when you're a comic
[Music]
if you come up to me and tell me
not to do a joke
you [__] up
and that's what anybody you [__] up
you go out there and the first thing
you're gonna do is you're gonna say that
[__] joke and look at that
[__] and go now what
now what
now what that's what r you cannot listen
it's not like i'm six and i can't cross
the street i get that command honey
you're gonna die you can't cross the
street but when you come up to me as a
club comedy club booker or an owner
and you said to me like you can't do
that joke because whatever you do that
joke and you take your lumps and
sometimes you win
9 out of 10 you will win trust me what
i'm telling you you'll win
because the word gets out that he's
doing that people are going to turn on
him and eventually
he'll come back to you you know how i
know because i did it to a thousand
those [__] i walked out of that
room out of that boise [__] room that
night she's sitting there with a fancy
little [__] uh you know sarah
mclachlan glasses on and [__] thinking
that she's going a little bit fair
and i was like i don't give a [__] what
you got to say to me watch my [__]
smoke and i walked out of that room and
if you don't think i was nervous for a
day or two i'm lying to you i was a
little scared of what i'd done my action
but guess what
in the end i prevailed like two years
later somebody said to me
not only is she getting out of business
she's closing the [__] club
like she had this little you know yuppy
contingency that was like like you had
to see how they treated her at this club
the employees
like she had them and i'm like
i've seen this before this is la
yoga chick [__] you know where they you
know oh my god i go to kickboxing who
gives a [__]
i'll take a girl from compton to come up
here and
[__] slap the [__] out of you with you
i don't care i go to kickboxing you
ain't [__] you got a cardio kickboxing
in studio city i'll pick up a nice
little black tough girl from compton
let's see what your cardio kickboxing
does get the [__] you know they show
up with their little hat with the
feather with the tattoo with the sleeve
rolled up so you can see the burden
their life or whatever leave me the [__]
alone guys i've seen those women come
and [__] go with their cuteness and
their [__] that was another [__]
witch that used to book cleveland and
buffalo
this [__] i remember her name her name
was sarah and i mean this girl was known
for hanging up the phone on you
real [__]
good looking though
whoo
sarah and i was throwing [__] heat
jack
little asian brunette tremendous but dog
the attitude of a [__] like a mutt
and she was another one that i you know
i got to l.a i'm doing good
i want to work miami i want to work
buffalo she booked buffalo miami
cleveland
so what this dirty [__] would do is she
would put you in cleveland first
in january she could freeze your [__]
dick off and then she would give you
buffalo and then she would give you
miami a year later i kept bugging her on
miami she's the one that kept bugging me
on buffalo and cleveland
so finally she gives me [__]
cleveland
and
i don't know everybody says she's very
nice i get there and this lady is a
[__] witch
from the minute and she got an assistant
who's a [__] [__]
this little [__] was a rat he
would tell her everything
like the first day i got there the only
lunch around was at a strip club they
had free lunch if you went in there
spent like five hours
oh my god they had the food came with
hair and pubic hair
[__] was floating in the air but dog but
when you're a broke comic you gotta do
what you gotta do [__] so
i had to do what i had to do so
you had to eat that [__] but i'll never
forget one night i went in there and i'm
like i need a 50 advance and she's like
you're not getting it
and by that point in my life
i was doing comedy about yeah i was
about the same it was about 98 i was
doing comedy about
eight years
when i tangled with sarah and i maybe
seven and a half years
first time i called her she gave me a
hard time second time i called this lady
says to me i'm gonna give you buffalo
and cleveland
and i go okay i was [__] excited as
[__] guys
i couldn't wait to get the [__]
buffalo i hadn't been to buffalo since
84. it was like 99 98. and [__] today
i'm gonna leave for buffalo the night
before i got a call that was right after
the sopranos blew up i mean right after
it was like
when the sopranos come on 99
it had to be like
march
april of 2000
i'll never forget i was at the improv on
melrose and my agent paid me that i got
a pennzoil commercial a pennzoil mafia
commercial this is when i was booking
those everybody thought i was big [__]
so i was booking those mafia commercials
to a [__] month jack
uncle joy was not [__] around those
days
no and uh
she [__] i called and i go listen man
i booked uh now anybody else would be
happy uh a club owner like if you call a
club on and go hey man i can't do
tuesday and thursday
because i booked a movie or something
they're like man that's pretty cool
okay coming thursday
no worries i'll fill somebody in for you
we're very proud of you when i called
this like oh sarah how you doing i i
i booked the penzo
campaign print
it's all gonna be mafia [__] i i can't
go to buffalo this week so she goes
well i'm canceling your cleveland date
also and hung up on me
i was like this is [__] up
this is [__] up that this lady
is uh doing this [__] to me so i took
the [__] hit
i waited like six months i called her
again she's like are you gonna cancel
the time
no
she goes okay i'm gonna give you miami
and cleveland i was like okay so i had
miami in december
and then i had cleveland the first week
of [__] january
miami was a [__] paradise
people flying through the air cocaine
some chick asked me if i could do a
headstand she'd suck my dick upside down
i mean miami
never disappointed in those days
now i get to cleveland like two days
after new year's day it's a [__]
two feet of snow
i get from the airport to the [__]
club
it's one of those deals where guys they
don't pick you up at the airport in
those days you better get to the club
however and when you got to the club
then they go okay now you got to get to
the condo where's the condo across town
you have no [__] idea what you put up
with so i had to go get the keys to the
condo
and right away she had remarks for me
about
working dirty
drug use you know
don't talk to the waitresses
just you know they give you the basic
[__]
i you know i asked the kid what do i eat
lunch she tells me go to the strip club
i go to strip club i come back that
night sarah is like how was your strip
club did you put a fight you know like
just there was just creepy [__]
people i look at the assistant i'm like
you're a [__] rat you little [__]
sucker
but the whole week this lady rode me
rode me and she threatened me like
thursday night she threatened me again
with the [__] if you don't if you do
that joke i'm gonna not give you work at
the other improvs
you know what i [__] did the joke and
that's the lady that when i asked her
for a draw
she said we don't give draws here and i
go listen
you got about five minutes to get that
[__] draw
well i'm gonna go back to my room and
[__] quit this week and i just
strained her in a little manage the dish
i asked her i asked her manager he went
to her and she told him i can't get a
draw i grabbed him and walked him into
the office and i go
he said i can't get a [__] draw she's
like you can't i don't give drawers i go
well you're going to make an exception
tonight
i lost my [__] credit card i lost my
atm i lost my wallet meanwhile i didn't
have a wallet on an atm card i had a
colorado driver's license or some [__]
and i just told her i go you're going to
give me the 50
she looked at me she said if i give you
the 50
you'll never work in one of my rooms
again i said give me the [__] 50
i don't want to work in your [__]
room again
she gave me the fifty dollars and that
was it
a year later she got fired
i'm not by me i didn't ride around i'm
not a [__] crime stop i just took the
fifty dollars and finished my weekend i
never even dreamed of calling them
anymore i was like [__] this [__]
a couple months later i got a call do
you want to work buffalo
i go not really another sarah nice book
in the room they're like nah sarah is
not associated
with the improvs no more so here there
was two situations where i [__]
thought my career was over with because
some and these are [__] funny bone
people and improv people
years earlier i had a
beef with a guy out of texas
that told me i would never work an
improv again if i didn't show up to his
gig
i waited till quarter eight that night
he called me he's like where are you
we're waiting on younger [__]
don't you ever [__] threaten me again
about a gig
you ever [__] threaten me again i'll
[__] go down there and i'll [__]
stab you i'm not going to your gig [__]
you you'll never work in this [__]
state of texas i know everybody [__] you
a year later i was in i was in houston
and guess what he had an opening in a
place called starkville mississippi and
when i got to houston that night they're
like hey man
whatever his name is tj or something
like that he's got a he's got an opening
in starkville
do you want to do it it pays like 250
i'm like dawg i'll definitely do it
but he's not going to put me in there
he's going to remember who i am
the kid goes let's call him so he called
him he's like listen
i got a headliner for tomorrow night
he's headlined the houston laptop
i hope that uh he could work with me
tomorrow and he'll drive
and the guy's like okay what's his name
and he goes joey diaz he goes hmm
that name sounds familiar he goes is he
there with you and i go yeah how are you
doing tj or tr
he goes good who am i speaking with joey
diaz he goes uh
how come your name sounds familiar i
don't know
because that this was when i thought
when i told him to suck my dick was in
i called him like in 2001 i was at the
houston lap stop maybe 2002 couldn't
could've even been later
so
i pick up the phone he goes yeah you
know give me a call tomorrow
morning i'll know more or less if the
show's gonna go on and if it's gonna go
on
i'll call you back and i'll give you the
itinerary where i called him at 901 the
next day
and i go how you doing tr tj whatever
your [__] name is what's the what
time is the gig and he's like who's this
and i go this is joey diaz because you
[__] he goes i looked through my
computer records last night you were the
one that didn't show up at that gig that
night and i ended up losing i go that's
right because you [__] threaten me
you [__]
and now guess what i'm [__]
headlining you dirty [__] what are
you gonna do to me now i'm not gonna
hide and he hung up on me and that was
the end of that [__] [__]
so don't let these comedy club owners
get in your [__] way guys don't do it
i will never do it i never allowed it
i'm you're going joey but look at your
level
i'm just telling you about a story from
and i'm telling you a story from 99 i
was at no [__] level but i believed
in myself
and i believed that these people
couldn't get in my [__] way and i
believed that these people weren't
strong enough to stop what i was doing
and guess what
with all my junky tendencies and the
drugs and the [__]
i was right
believe in yourself guys it's a [__]
monday morning
we got two weeks before the [__]
fourth of july
i'm going on the burke chrysler tour
this week and i hope
to see you guys uh whether it's in
bristol
south carolina
mississippi i'm looking forward to
mississippi i think i'm gonna eat some
of those [__] things that
my cousin vinnie what what when when he
went to my cousin vinnie went to
mississippi this
he ate that [__] that they give you it
looks like oatmeal and stuff in the
morning
i don't know it looks disgusting anyway
it don't [__] matter i'm excited
about this week
if you're a comic believe in yourself
don't let nobody [__] with you if you're
an artist believe in yourself don't let
nobody [__] you you know i was watching
that
cheryl crow documentary she's talking
about how
that guy the manager michael jackson
told her if he didn't suck his dick
she would never work again and she was
scared and she actually
wrote a song about
the sexual thing after the guy
threatened at the time that was [__]
michael jackson's manager if that guy
makes three phone calls you all [__]
work
but she believed in herself she wrote a
song about it and she's like [__] i'm
not going to suck this fat dick
i'm going straight ahead and guess what
he's dead of cancer
cheryl crow still rocking
believe in yourself on a beautiful
monday morning i love your [__]
stay black thank you for watching the
joint
and i'll see you [__] wednesday
afternoon
tip top magoo and now
for word for my [__] sponsor
jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank you
for catching a tremendous here beating
on the monday [__] morning you know i
love you guys
i'm always here for [__] to tell you
something about my life i don't give a
[__] anyway the joint is brought to you
by freeze pipe no matter how hot it gets
outside the freeze pipe will keep your
bung ice [__] cold let me tell you
something you don't know what it's like
to just go in the freezer take a [__]
compartment out slip it on to the
[__] pipe of debt and rip that
[__] when that strong smoke of
death from laughing gas passes through
the frozen part and you're just gonna
sit there going who's better than me
nobody that's what i'm talking about
with the freeze pipe whether you get the
bung the pipe or the bubbler it's always
a [__] party you think ac dc is in
your [__] backyard the freeze pipe is
non-toxic it freezes faster than water
and it stays frozen longer
freeze pipe cools down the smoke by
hundreds of degrees
to save your throat within all the ash
you eat and pubic hair and maluki juice
you gotta take care of your [__]
tonsils [__] and uncle joey's
here to take care of you so go to
freezepipe.com
press and code joey to save 10
off your first order get your bung
pipe or bubbler today uncle joey sent
you this is the
freezepipe.com the t-h-e freezepipe.com
press joey i'm going to save you 10
percent off the vig
if you can smoke it
freeze pipe will [__] make it
and the joint is also brought to you by
manscape listen
it's time you shaved your [__] ball
sack
around the [__] pogo stick and a
little off your [__] you're starting
to stink you smell it when you're
driving it that stink goes up but listen
manscaped is here to save you they got a
tremendous package i've told you about
the 4.0 razor i've told you about the
weed whacker
let's put it all together now now
they're going to give you something for
after you manscape your nut sac and
they're the boxes 2.0
tagless and made of buttery soft micro
fabric you'll want to pair these for
every occasion every time you sling dick
you want a pair of these and they come
with a feature a jewel pouch to keep
your freshly shaved balls and their own
little comfort palace
anyway that little jewel pouch is a
little stash if you need to bring a
[__] couple of tutsu with you and you
don't want to get stopped at the airport
you can also choose from the arrangement
of designs and colors
sizes range from small to 3x to big dick
mcgee
get 20 percent off plus
free shipping with code joey at
manscape.com again
20 off plus free shipping with coach
joey at manscape.com we've had this
conversation for [__] months it's
time you [__] took care of yourself
[__]
[Music]
manscape.com your balls will thank you
i'll thank you grandma thank you
and that's it pushing code joey i'm
gonna get you free shipping and 20 off i
want to thank the freeze pipe and
manscape but most importantly i want to
thank you savages
for another tip top magu show on a
monday morning stay black uncle joey
loves you and i'll see you wednesday
morning ready to stab a [__]
[Music]
you